c'est la française marie myriam qui a
remporté hier soir le grand prix
eurovision de la chanson
c'est une phrase qu'on n'a pas entendu
depuis 1977
la france championne de l'eurovision
avec ce titre d'un enfant aux yeux de
lumière qui doit passer au loin les
oiseaux comme un enfant qui surtout va
passer devant lui les récompenses
parce que depuis 44 ans la france n'a
plus jamais ramener la coupe à la maison
la première fois c'était en 1958
andré claveau micro et voici trente
secondes de bonheur consommer rideau de
bonheur c'est le seul français à avoir
remporté l'eurovision après lui que des
femmes la suivante s'est-elle jacqueline
boyer en 1960 avec son tube qui fera le
tour du monde comme bibi la fille du roi
lui sourit bergé l'amour l'amour l'amour
chanté l'amour qu'est ce qui fait gagner
la france
isabelle aubret en 1962 l'a bien compris
elle gagne l'eurovision avec le titre un
premier amour souriant de frêche blonde
il avait le bret va chanter un premier
amour et c'est franck pourcel qui va
diriger leur qu'istres tourillon frej
blonde
ok mais au passage un sacré coffre qui
lui fait gagner la compétition
[Musique]
quand je fais deux colis
qu'ai je fait le temps de bonheur
et après elle frida boccara en 1969 avec
un jour un enfant
[Musique]
ça
voilà ils sont tous là non champions
cinq vainqueurs depuis 1956 mais on le
sait l'importance et participer
[Musique]